so question 11 the speeds of a vehicle
are shown below in the cumulative
frequency histogram and you can see the
chart that's provided below what's the
frequency of the group with a class
center of 75 kilometers per hour so
let's have a look at what's going on
here across the horizontal axis so
that's this axis here we have the
vehicle speed in kilometers per hour and
the one that we are interested in right
now is that one that says 75 this guy
here so we want to know what's the
frequency of this particular group now
if I go up and read up like where does
that bar hit well up here that's where
the top of that is and I can draw a line
horizontally over to the left here and
you can see there I'm looking and that
seems like it strikes between 200 and
250 again there's the four marking so
they're going up in 10 so 210 220 230
240 so the one I'm interested in is 220
now 220 is not the frequency of that
class it's the cumulative frequency so
that includes all of the previous
classes in order to work out the
frequency of this class alone I have to
subtract all of the previous classes and
the way I do that is by looking at this
previous step in the cumulative
frequency graph when I have a look at
this bar here this bar here represents
not just the vehicle speeds of 70
kilometers about 70 kilometers and 65
and 60 and also 55 so if I go over to
the left again let's see that marks hits
the spot
so that looks like a hundred and thirty
if I'm reading that correctly so from
there I can say okay just that one group
is that distance there let's actually
move that a bit over so you can see it
more clearly
it's that distance from the 220 to the
130 so am i working out will be 220
takeaway 130 and I'm hopefully a mental
arithmetic is good enough to know that
that's a 90 all right now next step
construct a cumulative frequency polygon
or an ogive on the above graph now I'm
going to get rid of all of this working
here so that you can see the Oh guys I'm
about to draw as clear
as possible I'm gonna use a nice thick
black here so that you can see it now
accumulated frequency polygon is going
to join the bottom left corner to the
top right corner in a continuous line
from the bottom of the chart all the way
to the top so I'm gonna start right down
here you've gotta zoom in pretty close
at the bottom of the graph bottom left
to the top right there we go and
obviously you would use a ruler to do
this and you want to indicate it you
know very darkly on your exam paper and
then I continue this pattern going from
the bottom left to the top right there's
the bottom left to there and I'm going
to go up to the top right and I continue
this for the entire graph so I'm going
to go up yeah next one up and I'm going
to end up you can see it leveling out
here at the top right hand corner so
that's the yoga if that is the
cumulative frequency polygon and now I'm
going to use that so it's important that
you get this right because you're going
to get a result from it in the next part
I'm gonna use that graph to estimate the
median speed now we really need to pause
for it because there was a common
mistake here that I need to highlight so
what is median mean it's the middle of
the data set so if you had 101 people it
would be the 51st person is right there
down in the middle how do I get the
median from this well I need to know
what's the total number of people is 101
is a 301 and then I need to find who is
the middle of that now the trap here for
young players is that the top of the
vertical axis here you can see goes up
to 350 but there are not 350 data points
in here because you can see over here in
the top right hand corner the cumulative
frequency histogram never reaches 350
actually stops short at 300 that's the
actual total frequencies so therefore I
have to go from 300 divide that by 2 to
get my median it's actually n plus 1 on
2 if you need to be precise but because
we've got such a large number here the
precision between your one spot or half
a spot forward isn't gonna make a big
difference here and
300 roughly divided by 2 gives me 150
not 175 which is what you would have got
if you took 350 as the total frequency
there so to do this correctly I'm going
to go from there's 150 that's my median
position there and I'm going to draw
that across until I meet the owe guy of
the cumulative frequency polygon so I'm
going to draw that all the way here
there we go and then I'm going to mark
that down to yeah all right now I've
used the left hand a vertical axis to
find the median it's at 150 out of 300
I've drawn my line all the way across so
that it meets the oh guy so when it hits
across here with a rule it's critical
that that line is straight it meets
somewhere and then it's going to have a
corresponding speed and this is actually
the number that I'm interested in you
can see it says use your graph to
estimate the median speed and it's
important that it says the median speed
and not the median class because I need
to actually be quite precise here my
arrive needs to be accurate otherwise
I'm not going to match to this exact
spot now you can see here if you read
carefully this is 70 and this is 75 so
that would mean that in here that would
be something like seventy two point five
and so if I have a look there depending
on where exactly and how thick your line
is gone and that's gonna be either 73 or
74 I think it's a bit closer to 73 just
barely but either of those would be fine
so I'm going to write down approximately
73 and don't forget they have us for a
speed so if I have a look at the graph
it says this is in kilometers per hour
not miles or meters per second or things
like that
alright so that was using the Oh Drive
let's move on to question 12 the mean
weight of 14 Utah students is seventy
eight point nine kilograms when a 15th
person is included the mean increases by
one point
oh three kilograms what's the weight of
the fifteenth person all right now
before we tackle this question and start
to put some calculations in here
first thing we've got to do is remember
what what are we actually calculating
and how do we use that to form a
strategy to work out what the answer is
well this is a question all about means
and we usually indicate the mean all
right the mean as X bar and the mean is
equal to the total you know in this case
weight or maybe it was the number of um
you know points that were scored in a
game or the number of marks you got in
an exam whatever that total happens to
be in this case the total number of
kilograms and you're going to divide by
the number of people games of basketball
exams that you took the total number of
people who are included in this so if we
want to work out a mean you need the
total and the number of people who are
included in this case so if you want to
work out one of these you need the other
two now you can see for example you
start off being provided with two of
those figures for the original group
you've got 14 that will be the N in that
original group and then you've got the
78.9 which is the x-bar that's the mean
for that original group and then you get
given well kind of inferred new
information from here this increase of
1.03 kilograms relates to the means so
if you think seventy eight point nine
plus one point zero three that's going
to give me let's quickly think about
that that's seventy nine point nine
three kilograms that's going to be the
new mean of my other group and I've got
again another end here for the different
group so how do I piece all these things
together in order to work out the
solution well I'm going to say if I have
the mean weight of the original group I
can say that the total weight which is
the missing number the third number
which wasn't given to me before the
total weight of the original group of 14
is equal to let's see here well it's
going to be the 14 people multiplied by
their mean seventy eight point nine
kilograms now before I go ahead and
evaluate this I just want to make a
quick note about the working out that we
saw in this question it's
really common for students to just jump
straight to riot in 14 times 78.9 I
totally get that you're in a hurry you
don't have a lot of time to finish this
exam so you're under time pressure and
you already know what you're trying to
do the problem is if your solution is
just kind of a mess of this times that
that / that this plus that and then
there's no actual description like total
weight of 14 people what are you
actually calculating it rapidly becomes
unclear what it is that your answer is
supposed to be so your solution is not
well-structured
so that's why I'm gonna take the time to
write down total weight of 14 it
actually indicates off my calculations
mean and then I'm going to reach my
calculator it's gonna tell me then it's
1104 0.6 kilograms so that's the total
weight of the original group now when
you then go to work out the total weight
of the new group that total weight of 15
the difference between the group of 14
and the group of 15 is that 15th person
so once I have these two totals all I
need to do is subtract one figure from
the other that'll give me the weight of
the 15th person so let's go ahead and
work that out there's going to be 15
people and their mean weight remember it
increased by one point oh three
kilograms is going to be seventy nine
point nine three kilograms and again we
just reach for our calculator there and
punch in that set of numbers and that
gives us one thousand one hundred and
ninety eight point nine five kilograms
so the difference between this figure
here and this figure here that's going
to be my 15th person so that's what I'm
gonna write 15 person they're going to
be or their weight is going to be the
second number the larger one takeaway
the original number the smaller one and
again if we punch this into our
calculator you can see we're going to
get ninety four point three five
kilograms that's the weight of the
fifteenth person and that's how we
calculated it